hannover namens luca meine lieben
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
erneuten nicht lachen challenge
[Musik]
es sei immer mit der damals dass hamburg
das war früher das hotel lager das ging
die treppe hoch das ging jetzt wird das
gegentreffer
nach wenigen tage an
wir drehen
das ist
eigentlich nicht ich war halt so
glöckler platz irgendwie so hieß
eine dame hallo hallo
ja ja weil wir ihr drehbuch
wie heißt
das bringt mich für das richtig fand die
alte zuhause
dankeschön jetzt können wir weitermachen
in kassel
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich finde das alles nicht witzig das
todes fanny das genau ein dummer humor
sondern sitzen pinkeln uhr vom dings
spanier
mit 6
m bestmarke
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die türe so was nicht was mich immer
bewusst mit der ferse
oh mein gott walther ich mich welche die
schotten haben bei minecraft musik
[Musik]
waren wir in hamburg zusammen in diesem
restaurant da ab oder so wieder auf
sodass hieß wo dieses
desinfektionsgeräte wie so ein furtner
das kam so raus monate drauf gedrückt
das war nicht so dass ich
bin seine beschreibung stark versuchen
nicht zu lachen versuche nicht zu lachen
kartoffelpuffer versuche nicht zu lachen
ticken wir versuchen nicht so nach dem
motto versuche nicht zu machen katzen
versuchen nicht zulassen extrem schwer
mag ich versuche nicht zu warten derweil
versuchen nicht zu waffen deutschen die
eine stunde später er nicht lachen
challenge luger nicht lacht mit sandra
steht das andere klaren sandra nicht
lachen ständig mit luca nicht lachen
luca und sandra
nicht lachen luca deutschem ich
bin so ich ne
du dich fühlen das haben wir auch damals
immer so gemacht mit mario
[Musik]
karcher meist gelacht
wir gehen heute längst nicht
[Musik]
alle haben wieder damit dessen
abzuschauen alkoholtest ja ich habe so
etwas noch nie gemacht noch nie gepustet
gar nicht zumal zu hause gerade was
schon beim casting alkohol
nicht aber du hast paar andere ins
krankenhaus befördert wegen alkohol
mein gott
diese spiele die schmerzen gehabt neues
handy gekauft habe ich auch welche hast
du einfach drum kit nokia 63 00
[Musik]
warum
warum haben die teppichboden im raum
nochmals ja
was habt ihr für sich selbst geklatscht
ja oh mein gott
aber noch kein scheiß der hat eine
rückwärts seite gemacht und verrückte
zeit und dann auch selbst geklatscht
jetzt
aber muss ein hamster kaufen nein
liegt tiefer schnee nein
oder doch nicht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die kultur heißt auch dass man offen ist
für die bräuche und die kultur andere
länder wie heißt zum beispiel das was
alle nach dem essen in einem
griechischen restaurant umsonst bekommen
durchfall h
j eigentlich nach
betrieben doch immer oder
was trinken danach
was denken sich denn auch dass wir
hingehen
ein bisschen vom
bakom geil oder brauchst du vielleicht
doch irgendwie ein bisschen paradis ka
oder ein bisschen oregano auch noch ein
bisschen glück dabei
[Applaus]
ich liebe diesen youtube-kanal wie sehen
die aus können sie noch beschreiben dass
die an hatten ich
finde ich
keine personenbeschreibung
wird also keine beschreibung
aber vielleicht auch die hübscheste
mancher setzen
jetzt schon wieder so klar
[Musik]
die reden ja wirklich so nein noch ist
an der stelle würde ich heute nicht
lachen schon längst auf beende meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
das kann einen daumen hoch und dann
wieder ab und ihm einen kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn der weitere videos
nicht verpassen wollte sandra
ist vielleicht neue podcast online
gegangen
schnee ist gar nicht mehr
[Musik]
warum